hello and welcome to the nen world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today I would like to
touch on the protagonist of the current
succession walked in Hunter hunter being
Karaka and quite specifically why this
arc is more than likely going to see his
exit from the series so before we really
get into the meat of why this is
happening now specifically I do want to
bring up the idea that karuppa cos death
is a foregone conclusion in the series
not just because the arc of his
character in general motivations but
because the author himself Yoshihiro
Togashi has stated that korra pika will
be meeting his demise by the time the
series is over now the statement gets
thrown around a lot on the internet and
very very few people ever provide a
reference to it which annoys me to no
end
but footballs Tara T's sake this wasn't
answer that Takashi gave in an interview
in Honda Hunter folium 0 which was a
special publication that contains two
chapters detailing crop occurs past with
the kurta clan and ends with the news of
their massacre but also within the
interview section of the volume Takashi
is blatantly asked what will end up
happening to Korra pika and the Phantom
troop to which toga she equally if not
more blatantly states they will all die
pretty pretty straightforward answer
there I'd say but I should also point
out that this interview was published in
2013 and Takashi does have a habit of
you know changing his mind about
potential deaths when push comes to
shove so even with these words cropping
as death is still not 100% guaranteed
but I think that the overwhelming
evidence is very much in favor of him
passing on even without this togarashi
comment and it feels like we really have
known this effectively ever since
karappa KO was first introduced into the
story given that his entire character is
predicated on the concept of revenge
understandable revenge of course given
that his clan became the victims of
genocide for the sake of profit but his
sheer determination to enact retribution
has often twisted korra pika from
relatable protagonist into quite a
terrifying and ruthless being who under
different narrative circumstances could
even come to be considered a villain of
the series and I think that karateka
himself summarizes this perfectly with
some of the very first words he ever
spoke in the series when he stated I do
not fear death I only fear that my rage
will fade over time and I guess to be
fair that statement does also present a
potential outift oh gosh she's so
designed to choose for example during
whatever final conflict tropica has in
the series he could come to the
realization that pure revenge is much
less important than some other aspect of
life and allow his rage to fade away as
he feared in the beginning of the series
that would be
one way to twist it into a lovely
Chernin ending but at the same time this
is on to hunter in this world is not
known for being particularly forgiving
to anyone especially a character like
Rebecca who on his mission to reclaim
the Scarlet eyes of his clans folk has
stated that he has all something every
time he managed to reclaim part of his
brethren and the kinds of people that
karappa guitar guitar isn't limited to
mafia figures corrupt politicians or
even common criminals grafica has also
had to encounter more general people
like doctors musicians and even a
teacher to reclaim the Scarlet eyes and
in doing so he's had to resort to a lot
of less than savory tactics such as
threatening bribing coaxing and various
other methods although to his credit to
this point crop oka has always managed
to get what he wanted without killing
the former owners of the eyes still
whether or not that means he did so
without any form of violence or torture
has left much more in the ambiguous zone
of thought so I personally believe that
krupka is going to continue down this
path of self-destruction and inevitably
end up paying the price for said actions
and if that were to happen then there is
no greater stage than the succession war
arc for this climax and for some context
let's remember the entire reason why
tropica is even aboard the Blackwell one
to begin with it's so that he can obtain
a large quantity of scarlet eyes in the
possession of fourth Prince of the
cocoon Empire I'd Nick and in fact it's
also heavily hinted that this is the
last group of eyes that karappa canoes
to attain in order to complete his
mission the next up this is pure
speculation but this seems to be an
appropriate point to mention that there
is a decent idea floating around that
the eyes aren't everything at stake in
the succession war for kropog a-- so
ride nick is a well-known collector of
body parts in general and the
centerpiece of his collection is a head
that looks suspiciously like Pyro's who
was crop ACCA's childhood friend now
once again this is 100% speculation at
this point but it would make an awful
lot of sense because it is being kept in
the same section as the eyes of the Kota
clan and if it were to be true and it
only raises the dramatic stakes for Cora
pakka because at this point he is more
or less used to seeing the dismembered
eyes of his people however catching the
sight of Pyro's head well that would
push Kruger into a whole new world of
rage one that I highly doubt he would
ever recover from but back to what we
know for a fact it is thought by crop
ago that Surat Nick does possess the
lost of the eyes as stated before so
that is a mighty hint towards nature of
finality regarding crop akka in the
succession war but before embarking on
this voyage crop occur also lamented
that even after completing his goal he
would have no
left a return to and nobody to welcome
him back so it shows that he is very
much prepared for this to be where he
meets his in and while we're on this
idea let's also examine the owner of the
eyes Surat Nick because he is a very
important figure this man is far more
than a random Prince of the Empire and
as events stand currently he is most
certainly being built up to be the
primary antagonist of the succession war
with what he's demonstrated so far even
though he's only known about nen for a
handful of days this man is not going to
be easy to overcome even for an
individual of crop occurs sheer power
intellect and experience at his disposal
so right Nick has not only one but dune
and beasts one of which he conjured
completely naturally and subconsciously
and he has even developed an incredible
hatsune in his peril a future which
allows him to very briefly see events to
come and once he actually learns to
wield this in any form of adequate
manner it is going to be simply
devastating in any battle situation
furthermore I also think it's worth
noting that Surat Nick is a specialist
if only for the fact that it correlates
to crop occur zone an affinity when his
scarlet eyes are invoked but it also
presents a further challenge to overcome
because specialists can't be boxed into
typical men strategy I really do think
that if there's arc is shaping up to be
a conflict between sad Nick and Karaka
which every science seems to point to
then it's going to be one hell of a
hard-fought battle and something that I
don't think replica is going to emerge
unscathed from if at all but that isn't
quite the end so right Nick would
certainly seem to be cropping as natural
opponent but things have gotten far far
worse for our blonde revenge Smith
because also aboard the black oil one is
the entirety of the remaining phantom
troop a group that is tied more closely
with karateka than any other character
in the series bah he soccer I guess but
the Phantom troupe is incredibly
important because they were the ones who
conducted the actual genocide of the
Kota clan and harvested the scholar eyes
to begin with in fact as a result crop
occur crafted changer one of his most
powerful abilities with the strict
condition that it could only be used
against members of the troupe so this
tie is not to be ignored even though
neither party are currently aware of the
presence of the other right now the
Phantom troupe have their complete focus
on finding and killing Hisoka but the
moment they realize that crap echoes on
board that is going to trigger a change
in thought because when you think about
it Karaka is responsible for killing
just as many members of the troop as
Hisoka has managing to dispatch both
Vogon and park uno de during the yoke
new cydia and also it's not as if Cara
Pekka has no further investment in the
troop either the events of york new city
in no way settle the score from his
perspective and if an
when he finds out that the trooper
present all hell will break loose that's
very much why me Zeiss dome is currently
grappling with the idea of whether or
not to tell crop oka that he discovered
them so as to not add to the mental toll
already consuming him as part of the
succession war so while the goals of the
two parties are separate at the moment
narrative Li it's just far too
convenient that both karateka and the
troupe have been placed on an isolated
battleground for the next two months
along with the Scala ties it's as if
every threat of crop biggest story is
coming together and I guess the thing to
remember if you do want to put stock
into Takashi's quote is that he wasn't
just referring to crocodile but the
entire Phantom troupe as well
further connecting them in this story
but after all of this you might be
thinking yes sir I'd Nick and the
Phantom troupe are pretty tough
opponents but karateka is one of the
most capable people we've ever seen in
the series surely it's entirely within
his power to take out both of them and I
don't necessarily disagree with that but
even if he were to overcome both it is
going to come at a significant cost and
to get into that let's have a short
refresher of exactly how Cora pica is
able to be the beast level combatant he
is which is through the use of emperor
time emperor time is a maddening hot sue
that crop pika only has access to when
he has activated his scarlet eyes which
turned him from a conjurer into a
specialist an emperor a time then goes
on to allow him to use all fields of nen
at 100% efficiency from the perspective
of the base conjurer so it essentially
allows karateka to max out his potential
in any nen category without having to go
through all the training and mastery of
them however in exchange for this
ridiculous power every second spent
using Emperor time shortens crop occurs
lifespan by one hour so that's pretty
damn insane because if you even spent
half a minute with it invoked then
you've lost over a day of your lifespan
and that adds up very very quickly and
in fact we've already had a situation in
which an incredible chunk of crop occurs
life was shaved off when he fainted and
as a result he spent a total of twelve
hours with Emperor time active thus
removing five years of his life in one
swift move and look you can't say in a
serious like hunter hunter that that
might be meaningless because characters
tend to live much longer than humans in
reality but to those who argue that I
don't think you quite understand the
horrific situation the crop occurs in he
is currently embroiled in a death match
against ten remaining princes and their
parties two of which are already known
users and to further one happens to be
the unparalleled known prodigy Sir Adnan
meanwhile crop oka serves the 14th
prince by
the most understaffed and under
resourced party Karaka needs emperor
time simply to stay competitive let
alone to come out on top and the real
kicker is that this voyage is supposed
to last two months so that is an awfully
long and intense time to be operating
and of course Emperor time won't be
active for the whole thing in fact it's
not physically possible for that to be
the case because crop cope would die in
less than a week but he's going to need
to engage in very heavy and prolonged
use to make it through this war and all
of this isn't even considering the
amount of time he's already used the
ability for whilst fighting the Phantom
troop originally on his quest to recover
the Scala dies elsewhere and even when
he was vetting candidates for the hunter
exam with the Association by using
dowsing chain everything adds up and the
solution is not in Crocker's favor and
that's something that he himself has
flagged on multiple occasions now he has
blatantly stated that he must use it
carefully or even the smallest mistake
will prove fatal as well as that he was
incredibly naive when setting the
condition and didn't realize how truly
dangerous disability was and logically
this all adds up towards his demise but
more importantly it has been narrative
Leif lagged on multiple occasions the
idea of emperor time being a costly
ability keeps being referenced and there
is most certainly a storytelling
decision behind that which I believe
will culminate in you so extreme that it
will heavily contribute to or even
caused the death of karateka
and there you have it really whether
it's the quest for the Scarlet eyes and
the setting up with incredibly powerful
opponents well the fact that crop occurs
own abilities are rapidly depleting his
very life force there just isn't really
a favorable solution at hand I mean
unless something weird happens like he
ends up going to the Dark Continent
finding nitro rice and extending his
life but that seems very narrative Lee
dissatisfying especially for something
like that to happen after the succession
war because in theory this should be
tying up all of crop occurs remaining
story threads and from what we have to
go on in the 2013 interview
Takashi's intention was to kill Korra
pika and given everything that's
happening now I really don't think that
that has changed but that pretty much
does it for my thoughts on the
inevitable end of karateka if you
enjoyed this video and the content this
channel produced in general and please
do consider donating to the new world
review patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video a like share
or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel and
mount and if you'd like to join the fun
at anytime then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan retakes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on crop occurs final fate
in the series this has been the new
world review and I'll see you next time
[Music]